hi eighty I'm Aaron Creek oh and you're
on the set of when calls the heart come
on in
[Music]
so here we are in mrs. Thornton's
schoolhouse wow this is a moment this is
so cool so good so many big things have
happened the wedding sure you're
constantly teaching in here constantly
show me around this is my handwriting
this is this is a math assignment that I
wrote myself this was simple enough for
you to just do I could handle it could
handle this and this is where I sit this
is where I stashed my my phone and my
script in these little extra chalk it is
a functional drug this is jordyn I will
not come on this door does it outside
this is where we first discovered Cody
actually when are you going to come back
to school miss Thatcher so many neat
little things that you wouldn't
necessarily get to see the details of on
camera but there's like a little lesson
and everything that's hanging on the
wall is here plant life different kinds
of bird eggs
there's maps butterflies there's all
kinds of different things in here who's
the piano which we work with a little
bit this season so this is a real piano
it's cool
do you play I do not I can do a very
basic heart and soul every Joe and I
know what tiny bit to do you have to
reach a plate
[Music]
awesome if you ever need a piano extra
I'll call you miss Lake wouldn't know
about the back story nothing nothing you
know it's a pond we use it fairly
frequently Jack and Elizabeth have taken
a few boat rides on the pond they're fun
for you oh so fun to get in a boat and
just be out there on the water the
change of scenery yeah right over there
is where Jack proposed to Elizabeth will
you marry me yes so that was a pretty
magical moment in the history of phone
calls the heart yeah it's just covered
in candles really romantic and pretty
this is where Jack and Elizabeth first
meet actually he comes down the stairs
he's just been staying up there and the
Lizabeth is working on something on the
chalkboard and what's where they first
meet what are these doors lead to up the
stairs well we can check it out let's
check it out okay do you want to know
something funny I actually don't know if
I've ever been all the way up these
stairs
it's an easy first I'm serious
this is so weird as I'm walking up these
steps I don't think I've ever been up
here and that's probably because there's
nothing up here I mean so it's it's more
movie magic guys if you go up this way I
do happen to know well look it's a bit
of a disaster
this is cool or what so beautiful and
real like is it so real
no they're not so okay
this set has live animals this is so
cool there's a horse right here you know
it's just one of them the Mounties gave
Elizabeth Jack's horse last season so
now I'm writing this brand-new horse who
is bigger and faster and more of a
challenge but I'm really enjoying it it
was so great to have you but I got to go
from another scene so goodbye